[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
why
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
why
oh
[Music]
hey friends wasn't that Fountain cool I
discovered that just up the street uh
living here in Silver Spring Maryland
just outside of DC and uh I had no idea
it was there but uh I think it made for
a really cool visual although the
pounding waves did make it on occasion a
little bit challenging to hear the music
but I think the results turned out great
in the end so real quickly huge thank
you to ultra poy for sponsoring this
video and giving me a reason to go out
and explore new spots in DC if you'd
like to get a set of those or poy Pro
that I was using in this video you can
do so by using the promo code direct
factor with a zero instead of an O at
checkout over at ultra.com that gets you
a discount and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins thank you so much to
ultra poy for sponsoring this video and
speaking of thank yous I have to offer
up thanks to the Friends of the channel
big thanks too dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyot
ter light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- buus friend of the
channel Becca be thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
awesome so um this video and all the
videos on this channel are made possible
by my patrons on patreon uh in
particular I want to single out my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you so much for your wonderful
support for making all of these videos
possible uh and thank you out there for
watching this video if you'd like to
check out more of my flow and
performance videos I will include a link
to a playlist of them down in the
description and if you'd like to sign up
to support my work on patreon you can do
that also at a link that I will leave
down in the description thanks so much
for watching have a good one and I'll
see you with a new video real soon peace